we're in the Austrian Alps near the town
of leans in Tejon it's home to a very
strange looking building viewed from the
front it looks like a bird seen from
behind it resembles a UFO
architect Peter Youngman created the
unusual dwelling called the you Fogle
together with his son Lucas Oh big this
is supposed to be an emergency shelter
who didn't know where it would be
located exactly so we put it on stilts
that way it could have been placed
anywhere neither India fought side and
this beak like extension that makes the
building look like a bird is actually
designed to protect it against the snow
in the mountains shoots wash Nemo
Gardena life
the slanted side walls also protect the
entrance from snow now the you Fogle
houses a mini hotel with a designer
bathroom underfloor heating and air
conditioning an overnight stay costs 120
euros the huge windows allow guests to
really soak up the scenery the you Fogle
is built only from wood glass and stone
analysis or all the materials that have
been used to constructed our
locally-sourced this includes the larch
wood from which the entire structure is
built to fit all the seating and storage
areas are made of wood
so what's it like to actually stay here
nature enthusiasts Zeman Boatner is
about to find out the hotel can sleep up
to eight guests but Zaman has the whole
place to himself and he's loving it
windows allow lots of light in its cozy
z1 likes the unusual details a glass
wardrobe with a view of the shower and
remote-controlled blinds cool he feels
at home here the place is small but it
doesn't feel cramped these windows make
it seem as if I was living in nature
the kitchen is equipped with all the
essentials it even has an induction hot
plate even so
Simone's only making spaghetti because
he prefers to relax
who cares the kitchen is high-tech
spacious everything is cleverly laid out
I'm moving here in an instant
the Italian scene
and then night falls z1 gets the fire
going even though the hotel offers
underfloor heating
to create the bathroom is tucked away
but it leaves nothing to be desired the
hotel has running water and electricity
and is connected to the local grid
Zeman's verdict
it was a relaxing day I've discovered a
lot in the house and it'll probably be a
fantastic night and I'll sleep really
well very cozy so much wood and glass
things to discover in every corner I
could easily spend my whole holiday here
the you Fogel an unusual hotel for
nature lovers who don't want to miss out
on their home comforts